Dakota it is so lovely to be here with
you today thanks for the conversation
yeah thank you for having me of course
so I'm wondering to start what
experience or Insight made you want to
start your own company
yeah it's uh it's really a funny story I
grew up and as I was a kid I'd worked in
my family business which was a trucking
Fleet and I got to move trucks around
and fill them up with diesel and really
got to intimately learn and understand
the industry and I saw a lot of the
problems and a lot of the challenges
that we faced and that's what prompted
us to really start exos is some of the
experiences I had there cool tell me a
little bit more about those experiences
yeah so we were actually based in
California and we had a large Fleet of
heavy duty diesel trucks and one of the
things I was tasked with doing is
figuring out how we were going to
address the new emissions regulations
that were impacting some of those fleets
and so I started doing research and
looking into all kinds of different
things like biodiesel and compressed
natural gas trucks and even electric or
hybrid trucks at the time and that's
really what kind of prompted me to say
hey wait a minute these emissions
regulations eventually look like they're
going to go to full zero emissions and
nobody's building a fully electric
commercial vehicle right now and I saw
that when you look at fleets versus
Passenger cars they were actually ideal
candidates for electric vehicles they
returned to base they do under 200 miles
and they generally return to a dedicated
charging location so it became kind of
this Epiphany that I just said why not
do it nobody else is doing it yeah oh
that's really cool
you started your own company
even the ground up
approach to building your own team and
how do you think about company culture
when doing that that is probably one of
the challenge most challenging things in
scaling any business
I have always kind of had this
perspective that I'm really just kind of
a central coordinator there and I need
to hire and really retain and attract
the best kinds of people right and every
area of the organization it's not just a
great CTO or a great CFO it's at every
level and in every every different
function and I think in doing that you
you really try to hire folks that you
want to work with and you want to spend
your day with and that doesn't mean you
hire your best friend but it means you
hire people that challenge you that hold
you accountable and push you to new
heights and I think I've been really
fortunate to have an amazing co-founder
that helped do that but also really
we've been fortunate to have incredible
people throughout the organization and
building culture isn't something that's
like a single task you can't just create
a good break room and then you know your
your Google overnight right
um it's it's something that takes a lot
of work it takes a lot of time and I
think building culture kind of revolves
around building trust and with the
relationships and the people that you
work with
absolutely and So speaking of challenges
which you just brought up what were some
of the challenges that you and your team
faced when first scaling up your company
yeah there's a long long list of
challenges I'm sure
um you know I think one of the ones that
people talk about a lot is fundraising
and when you're starting a new startup
there's a lot of different strategies
and approaches as to how you can
fundraise and raise Capital but raising
capital for a manufacturing business
which is inherently very Capital
intensive was one of the most
challenging things we ever did we talked
to hundreds of investors and continue to
talk to many investors in this industry
about what we're doing and our mission
and how we're trying to solve a really
big problem but a lot of times you know
you get to know and that can be you know
a letdown so managing that process and
managing the entire communication you
know stream with investors was
incredibly challenging I think the other
thing which kind of ties to my first
point is actually building a physical
product building Hardware is incredibly
challenging to start with and then you
layer on all sorts of things like
regulation
you know tariffs all kinds of external
factors that you have no control over
but have to plan for those are those are
really challenging parts of the business
that sometimes you don't know what
you're missing or you don't know what
you don't know yeah so speaking of
raising funds and money what would it
take to get you to sell your company
that's a good question it's a little bit
like a personal you know I wouldn't call
it a child but it's that level of a
relationship uh I you know there's I
don't know to be honest I can't can't
answer that question for you I'm
invested in it and I come to work
because I'm excited not because I get a
paycheck and that's that's really the
motivating factor for me I'm excited
about really solving a big problem yeah
when you look at this business one of
the reasons why we started it was it
wasn't just about building something
that scaled and was super profitable
it's a triple bottom line business so
people profits and plan it and I think
when you look at new businesses today in
our generation we're focused on doing
something but doing something with
purpose and it's exciting for me because
I know even if we're not delivering a
million trucks the next year every truck
we deliver is actually making a
difference and it really keeps you
motivated particularly as you're going
through difficult times whether it's
Supply or whether it's hiring or
investing or raising money
you you have that kind of ultimate kind
of motivator which is you're doing
something good for the planet and it
keeps you on course
excellent so me I am a lifelong learner
I love to read I love to learn I'm sure
a lot of co-founders and Founders like
yourself feel the same way what is one
lesson or one thing that you still are
hoping to learn
that's also a really good question and
the list is really long
and this is uh you know being very
transparent I'm still learning how to
balance your kind of home life and also
the work life and I've become so
invested and so passionate about the
business that at times you forget to
focus on family or your friends or you
know making sure that you have enough
space to you know ensure your mental
health is okay and I think that's that's
something I'm continuing to learn but
one of the things that really in
addition to that that motivates me about
this industry is it's constantly
evolving and I really really love the
technology that we're working on because
it's not just about building a truck
it's we're solving issues that have
never been solved ever before right
building
long-term Lithium-ion batteries that can
be 100 recyclable that that really solve
the climate crisis like those are Big
Technical challenges that every day get
me excited to to just even show up
awesome
um and last question for you yeah where
do you see both yourself and your
company five years from now
uh that's a great question
um I hopefully see myself right where I
am and in terms of you know working with
exos
um personally and and professionally I
think I would like to see a lot more
growth in terms of learning about the
future of the industry the future of how
we can continue to make a difference in
the climate problem that we're dealing
with
um and I really think access will be the
leading solution in this industry you
know I think for us we've seen how the
traditional oems are really slow to act
and to change and they're only doing
this because they're being forced to
we're doing it because we're passionate
about it we want to actually solve a
real problem here and we can do it
profitably and so I think there's
there's nothing really holding us back
awesome well thank you so much for for
the conversation in the chat this has
been wonderful thank you appreciate it